alice first of all congratulations you
started off the day blazing hot with a
victory but after that tatev bounced
back with two victories in a row forcing
you to win on demand how uh did you
approach that difficult moment
i mean after i lost the first game in
the rapid match um like i kind of
thought that like uh i was losing so i
just was like okay just like play chess
um she surprised me in the opening a bit
but i think i was able to handle it
reasonably enough and of course
armageddon was a bit chaotic
tell us
were you worried because in this match
well you did not make a single draw
and she got white and she had to win
were you worried about this tendency of
you uh ladies not making any draws in
this match
uh yeah
i mean
uh
her opening was a bit
strange like was the bishop e2 and move
seven but um
i think i'm pretty comfortable with the
qga although in this game i think i was
like probably losing out of the opening
um but of course yeah i was a pretty big
concern that she might try to
beat me with the white pieces especially
since the record was
2-0
one thing that you
did quite consciously was play fast in
the opening and you play this move
castle and we thought that she had this
queen to b7 attacking the knight which
was pinned on the d-file were you
worried about uh this move did you spot
it during the game
oh queen to b7 oh i should probably be
winning uh i was actually only looking
at queen c6 and for k7 but queen b7
should be just be losing the piece and
after knight to c5 who takes the eight
knight takes b7 and rook to d7 the same
pattern that uh you encountered in the
game against tavroula earlier in the
tournament
yeah i just wanted to say alice i mean
had you won
the coin toss
what color would you have chosen to play
in the armageddon i probably would have
chosen to play white because like first
of all there weren't any draws uh
second of all like the time advantage
can be pretty important
um
but then the next question i ask for you
is you are aware that a draw wins the
match right yeah so exactly in this
position when tata played knight e5
i thought that this was your opportunity
to trade queens
yeah just trade queens but you played
bishop b7
and traded pieces rather in the wrong
fashion got yourself into a world of
trouble and this might have been the
easier way for you to try to make a draw
yeah i mean i considered trading queen
for like um probably like one second but
then i thought that this end game might
be like more passive to play um of
course i didn't exactly see how losing i
was i knew i was worse but yeah here
um trading queens probably would have
been better strategically right and from
the from the match perspective but well
done young lady i mean you're you're
going to be facing uh
eight-time u.s champion arena crush once
more how do you feel about that
um well mostly i'm relieved to be able
to win this match but um
i think against irena it will probably
be like tough but
i'll try my best
very good very good eliadra no just very
impressed with the way that this young
lady handles herself and just
comes back from any position very
accurate calculator alice really looking
forward to what you're going to bring
against irena okay last and last and
last question alice i have
told these gentlemen
that they've got to ask for you a full
scholarship right here right now
and that furthermore you've got a choice
where would you rather go to saint louis
university
or the university of missouri yes sir
dirty dog
putting the pressure on everything i
started thinking have you started
thinking about your university uh no
it's doing like five or six years
well
give it some thought because uh the
these coaches are anxious to have you
good luck alice we'll be here with you
tomorrow thank you thank you and a
reminder for you guys what we have for
tomorrow two classical games it'll be
levon aronian against aviano caron